quite welcome to co playing of that
Latakia set a jerk Alejandro needle man
okay let's see what he's got in stone to
a three okay the office leasing is a
bullet game and that's funny not even
pretending to to think about okay anyway
he wants to go Bishop g5 and my apron is
hanging
hey is a little bit better here that is
just what it is even though he treated
like a bullet game white has an
advantage not entirely sure what I did
wrong maybe a high B 5 a-4 so i'm not
sure him i don't have that much
experience with this position time i'm
trying out this opening currently but I
lack experience with be five maybe Luke
c5 becomes an option to to to look at
this d5 pawn Iook we need to
okay so maybe I should do this right
away on c4 IM b5 so in case of Queenie
true i can go g5 probably and then take
okay so he wants to double just double
understandable if i take 33 here what
then rupee and look moose but mainly
sister interesting be 3 45 is weak as
well so take it I mean d5 is hanging
okay so rookie five okay so probably 23
attacking my bishop and now look you 112
oh look you one of the ship see success
the ship c6 is not bad I mean I'm still
attacking the bishop and b2 is hanging
okay look the one takes takes 21 I don't
know if this better actually tough to
say we should be three maybe now we have
maybe
PPP five people can also check I'm not
sure that this is doing me that good am
I sure I should have done that and let's
check our Liam yes yet thinking now is a
totally one-sided position but probably
just a draw so I'm keeping keeping
everything on the board
and not sure if I have some winning
ideas here or not like a direct winning
ideas i can always always just play for
the ending and then claim my bishop is
good but it might it might just be a
case where he SF ask some type of
fortress
you
[Music]
okay let's gain a little bit of space
threaten Bishop b5 maybe not a big
threat
I don't have a concrete idea with this
is thrilling just looking actors I
thought we should before isn't that
great but maybe I'm wrong
time learning
a three and so it's a good move check
check
yeah he's certainly right and training
queen okay with having as much of a time
disadvantage will be easier to defend
okay okay I learned that this holy cow
and I have got no time it's one of the
few possibilities to lose this game on
time he better the whole whole thing
okay black realize yeah yeah I'm it's
tough to win them it's really tough to
win I think maybe maybe here I didn't
didn't kill him or somehow it should be
it looks really wrong for whites here
around him okay I wasn't sure checking
or yeah all the immediate check I wasn't
sure it also looked good but yes I mean
this ending is of course nice but you
probably cannot win even though you have
the two bishops because of the symmetry
and this is probably better at ya look T
1 is may be wrong b5 before ok ok yeah
it's always difficult with one minute
down I mean white can just shut
around without any particular purpose
and the things was at the end with black
can do okay get get anywhere on autumn
okay this little actually rather
promising start I mean here I have
something that maybe maybe you cannot
win it definitely difficult with 20
seconds so yeah Bishop f8 I didn't
didn't see this move so I have to do
this and I dominate the night and make
maybe it's a troll I mean what can
probably hold that the ad i used to use
too much time and he has the auto thank
you which is always liked him I don't
know Jim I don't like the opening with
our drilling let me shake it oh hang on
oh and the engine is equal ish the whole
time yeah engine likes my position it's
it's rather better than anything else
okay now i'm reasonably okay there may
be here i should have sister can't it
played a lot quicker from the get-go or
just I mean sometimes like I mean I can
just do this and always be eternally
better it's also possible I click this
and here you can play movie and moves
with black without thinking this is may
be easier if you're not running into
some kind of and whatever some kind of
four core so winning it will be will be
again difficult but maybe you have
better chances to not lose on time okay
thanks for watching